hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the 2019 FIBA World Cup
we've entered the Blitz section so after
the 2 class after the fall for classical
games they went into the rapid section
all for rapid games were drawn and now
we are in the blood section so if two
more blitz games are drawn or if each
wins one games and we entered the
Armageddon so this is a game one of the
Blitz and the dink has the white piece
so we're not going to over analyze it as
it is blitz but if an interesting really
interesting line occurs of course we
will show it so with the white piece
pieces ding opens with Knight to f3 with
Knight to f6 g3 with d5 by the job of
and Bishop the g2 so the rate is on the
board we have E six castles binding and
the Bishop to e7 also preparing the
castle d4 we have castles by the job of
and now c4 d captaincy for Queen to c2
going after the pawn and a six now
allowing White's to capture on c4 with a
four first preventing beef sorry that's
not a b5 preventing b5 and now Bishop to
d7 better job of as a white will most
likely recapture the pond you want to
transfer your bishop to this very nice
diagonal so Queen captures on c4 biding
and now Bishop to c6 we have Bishop f4
biding and now Bishop to d6 offering
another trade and now Queen back to C 1
if if captured then the Queen can
recapture on e4 instead of the pawn
Knight be c7 Knight B to d7 and now rook
to e1 biding with Queen to e7
developing the Queen connecting Brooks
in the Knight to c3 and here we have
Bishop captures on f3 Bishop captures on
f3 Bishop captures on f4 Queen captures
on f4 and mouse c6 here and this just
proves how deep reserves preparation
goes as ding already had his position on
the board in the 2017 world rapid
championship against patrol echo and the
game continued in the same fashion being
played a five against Lego and the
difference is Lego in that game played a
5 right away whereas our job of improves
it with rook a to D 8 so rook 88 is a
new move in the
as of most 16 which basically tells us
that our job of knows about the game
being played against aleyko even though
it was a rapid game and that he is very
much prepared to play this position so
rook sorry rook eat the one biting and
now comes c5 as it's prepared both Queen
and night guard that pawn queen - III
you cannot recapture as the Queen is
hanging on e7 so rook ft 8 just getting
a defender to the Queen and now d5
biding so here you have to decide
whether you want to trade here or do you
want to push efore Rajah both bushes
efore and now Dean has to decide whether
Bishop to g2 or D captures on c6 so Dean
decides for Bishop to g2 and now comes C
capture Sun d5 Knight captures captures
with rook captures and now Knight to f6
offering more captures we look after
sandy eight rook captures and now h3 so
we have a disposition where white seems
to be a little bit better because of the
blockade on the Queen side blacks Queen
side pawns aren't really going anywhere
and the e4 pawn for a moment seems to be
a bit weak so order double has to show
us what he prepared with Queen to b4
putting pressure on the a5 pawn as the
rook and come to d5 go after the pawn
also pressuring the B to pawn b3 biding
defending it and now with h5 here raja
baath likes his position he wants to
always have an option of playing h4 also
creates an additional escape Square for
the King if needed just a very useful
move came to h2 biding improving the
position of his King and now comes Luke
the d5 going after this pawn here there
were a lot of ideas here maybe want to
go Queen to d2 trade Queens may be Queen
to d4 try and force a Queen trade as it
comes with an attack on the rook what a
job of tries an active plan going after
the a5 pawn and now we have Queen to f4
biding which is which is interesting as
well you have to ask yourselves what
happens after rook to a4 it's an
interesting line so we're going to show
it at a jobs plan was a Queen to e1 and
it gives up a pawn but for a very good
contra play for example Bishop captures
on e4 Knight captures rook captures now
comes the rook rook to the
and now if you don't want to get made it
you have to do something
rook e8 check King h7 and now Queen to
f4 check which now allows you to gain
control of this diagonal g6 and Queen to
g2 you're up upon but you will have
you'll have your hands full defending
this position and if black wants to he
will always be able to pick pick the
boner back
so after looked at the five we don't
have this idea of rook to a4 but rather
dingos for Queen to f4 and okay we have
rook captures on a5 now rook captures
Queen captures and now the idea behind
Queen to f4 Queen to b8 check came to h7
and now you pick up the b7 pawn and now
Queen to f5 buy a job of going after the
f2 pawn with King to g1 now defending
and here III or a job of sacrifices upon
you don't want to push something like F
3 or a 4 here then it's well it's just a
very dangerous pawn on e3 so here being
captures that he's up upon but his most
of pawn structure is a bit messed up
Queen to east six now attacking well
pressuring the b3 phone really but
attacking the e3 pawn king to have two
defending and now here the the time on
the clock is one minute versus 30
seconds or a job of really down on the
clock we have Queen to f5 with Czech
Queen back to f3 defending and now Queen
back to e6 attacking the b3 pawn and
here ding manages to defended with E 4
so now the B three ponies defended by
the Queen and he gets to keep his extra
pawn with g6 better job of and now comes
King to g1 ding wants to put pull back
his king so it will be much safer there
and now Knight to d7 so it's a really
awkward position but even though ding is
up 1 he has three point islands and the
doubled epon it's going to be very hard
to capitalize on that Queen the c3
budding not allowing night to c5 to go
for the double attack against the pawns
and now Knight to e5 with B for biding
cementing that a6 bone on a light square
and now Queen to d6 we have a kink to f2
now the King will also help out with the
defense of the points and here both
players are below 10 seconds playing on
that 3
in increment so you can imagine things
were very crazy here so nice the seasick
with a double attack on the b4 pawn
queen sefa no that's not what happened
Queen c5 just offering to trade Queens
and defending the pawn and now Queen to
d4 check here our job of forces of trade
with captures captures and now II five
in the knife to see to Raja bow goes
after the b4 pawn to create a path bone
of his own and now comes a bishop to d5
saying I want to grab the f7 pawn at a
job of defends it and now east six with
F captures Bishop captures and Knight
captures on b4 so the material on the
board is equal now but Roger bow has a
past a point on the other hand a ding
has a bishop against tonight so with
with play on both sides of the board
Bishop should be preferred with Quinta
III and now King to f6 Bishop back 37
and now kink the e5 with the shove the
yet going after the pawns here and now
Knight the d5 with check King D 3 and
not Knights the e7 so using the checked
or even over the Knights to defend his
pawns
we've kinked a c4 now Dean wants to go
after the a6 pawn and now a5 taking away
the the be 4 square with King to c5 and
now King back to f6 by a job oh and here
like I said all both of them are very
low on the clock and here you want to go
Bishop to b5 but pink one King to b5 and
he enters a race so my Queen side pawn
for your King side pawns let's see who's
faster and okay Knight to f5 goes after
the g3 pawn with 8 King captures here
the night cat person g4 and now Bishop
back to b5 defending the e2 pond with g5
and the King before now dink has to get
his King back into the game with kinky 5
King to c3 and now came to f4 and here
doing the Miss plays instead of sorry
instead of king before he went king to
be to what you want to do is play king
d4 here and now even if you're checked
then you go King to D 3 and now King the
g3 is met with the very strong efore so
now you will lose this pawn but you're
passed upon will give you enough count
counterplay but here dingos kings to d2
and now the position really gets missing
we have Knights the e4 check King that
you want and knocking to g3 and now as
you can see it's very different it's
similar but instead of you being able to
start pushing you're a pawn there's a
knight on e4 blocking you
so Bishop d7 defending the pawn here but
now h4 with III biding and night the f2
going after the h3 pawn there's no way
to defend it we have King to f1 and now
Knight captures on h3 or a jobber wins
the pawn and only now can ding start
pushing the pawn with Knight to f4 and
now e 5 with h3 and now comes a bishop
to c6 keeping an eye on this diagonal
but now h2 we have a bishop back to b-17
just has to wait and see what our job
will do and now g4 preparing to move the
King and start pushing the Jeep on as
well we have a bishop to c6 and then out
comes King to h3 and here
the Shabak to b-17 doesn't have an
active plan here g3 and now Bishop the
c8 check here King has to go back we
have King to h4 and now Bishop back to
b7 so it seems like ding is holding here
but now our job goes after the past pawn
and with that gun it's gonna be it's
gonna be pretty much game over
Bishop the e4 not allowing the king to
approach the pawn and now King back to
g4 with east 6 giving up a pawn but
there there is no other move we have
Knight captures on e6 and now came to g2
this allows the King go back into the
game but now Knight back to f4 check
King h1 and now Knight to h3 and here
didn't give up his pawn they was pretty
much the only thing he could do to try
some sneaky ideas like disruptive f3
check he played this of course it for a
job of characters it's a stalemate
haven't a job of did not capture with
came to f4 and now comes came to g2 so
defending it but now knife to f2 and
here your Bishop is no longer guarding
the h1 square so h1 Queen is the threat
being move the King King to f1 and of
course now for a job of just recaptured
the sorry captured the bishop on f3 and
it was in this position that ding
resigned the game as well he has to move
the King and then a queen enters the
game with chair
so a tough break for ding after after
you know getting a lead in the classical
time format then our job of equalized
then a for rapid games run then first
blitz game with the white pieces a loss
for ding Liron but tomorrow job of
brilliant game with black really spent a
lot of time but Indian he just showed
what a what an incredible fighter he is
and he took bounding in in the blitz
blitz section and I don't have to remind
you that ding was the world blitz
champion at one point so I'm really
really insane next game thing gets the
black pieces and he will get his chance
to retaliate so as soon as you finish
watching this game most likely I will be
uploading the other game as well so
we'll see what happens there so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Federman
Albion line of Saran and the Charles
trader for a conversion to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
the next game of the of the Blitz
section so so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day